What if we want to run
two versions of nginx.
What happens when we install it again?
Using our Package Manager,
let's try to install nginx again.
It says it's already installed and
we have the newest version.
So, that's not how you do it.
Let's try starting nginx again and
checking the status.
I still only see one
instance of nginx running.
And we can confirm this
using the ps command.
I can see that there is only one
nginx process and it's worker.
So that tells me there's only one main
instance of my application running.
So, without going into all the details,
to create two instances of
nginx using native OS tools,
we'll need to modify init scripts.
It takes a lot more work.
In particular,
you have to modify this file.
We'd also need to manage ports
because two instances can't
bind to the same port.
There's a lot of complexity here and
that's not even considering how
to run a newer and
older version of nginx at the same time.
Most OSs only allow you
to run one version.
So we're going to have to change things
up a bit and take a different approach.
So let's stop nginx.